just a reminder if you want to get on
with me today your nickname in the
waiting Lobby should be your name and
where you are calling from
um nicknames and this sort of thing uh
will will not get you on just so
everybody knows let's go next to Evan
from Las Vegas Nevada Evan welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
hi David thanks for having me my
pleasure um I was wondering your opinion
about when we heard Josh Shapiro's
speech I think was last week which was a
great speech yeah I thought he made a
great point about uh like how
Republicans have kind of become even
though they claim to be this Freedom
Party they're really the anti-freedom
party they're against abortion they're
against uh you know teaching theories
that they might agree with they're
against parents deciding with their kids
what they want to do with a doctor
Etc do you expect Democrats to kind of
use that talking point more because I
personally think it's a great talking
point I I think absolutely the case it
it I think it absolutely is the case
that it should be used listen they love
talking about freedom and yet they want
to take Freedom away from you in schools
in your bedroom at your doctor's office
and on and on and on and I think it I
think it makes absolutely perfect sense
it breaches it's sort of um straddles
economic and social issues they want to
take away your freedom to organize a
union if that's what you want to do you
know all these things I think you know
your freedom to uh shop around for
prescription drugs or insurance or
whatever the case may be I think it's an
excellent talking point I'm not really
like a focus group guy so I think the
experts need to do some brainstorming
and sort of figuring out the exact right
way to do it but I think absolutely 100
percent
great yeah no I've used it just
interpersonally with friends that maybe
not aren't like crazy trumpists but I
have some friends who are like you know
kind of in the middle yeah and it seems
to click I mean they're at least they
don't have a good argument against it
you know absolutely because it's the
truth that's the reality you the the
arguments work you know Republicans have
made a pretty good Headway with
arguments that are lies but arguments
that are the truth I think work even
better
exactly okay thanks David all right
thank you my friend very much appreciate
hearing from you